hello everyone welcome to another
technique class at home i hope you are
all doing very well
today will be a class mainly for men
because
we will work on heroes and specifically
on the steps
of the man inside the heel yeah
as you know when the woman is doing a
hero around the man
her steps for example if she starts
from a cross and with a notch
forward yeah around the man usually her
steps
are always front side
back side front side
back side front and so on yeah
and the man usually walks forward
yeah of course using pivots so that his
walk
is a circle yeah so the man would walk
forward like this using pivots inside
the structure
of the steps of the woman so in today's
class
i will give you four different sequences
that you can practice
alone at home and each sequence
will be a different structure of how you
can use your steps
inside the heel of the woman so
in today's class we will start with a
warm up
and then we will see these four
sequences one after another
first we will do them to one side to the
right
and then we will do them to the left so
that you can practice
both directions of the hero and we will
also do them
first slowly one step per beat
very slowly so that you can focus on the
structure and on the technique
and then we will do them faster in half
time
which is how you would normally use
those combinations in your dance
so let's go for the warm up okay warm up
so
let's as always put our feet together
and just spend a few seconds finding our
center
breathing deeply relaxing the shoulders
letting them go down
and letting our hallway go down through
our feet
on the floor yeah and we start with
shoulder rotations yeah remember them
very big
yeah as big as you can and don't use the
elbows now we will do
eight one
two three
four five
six seven
and eight now we do arm circles yeah so
remember
the most important thing is to keep your
elbows always straight
yeah you move your arms
forward then up and then you open them
to the sides
and your hands are a little bit behind
your back so that you really stretch the
chest muscles and then down again
yeah and we will do eight so
one two
three four
five six
seven and eight
okay yeah make sure that you relax the
shoulders when you do the
um the arm circles now we will
stretch the side of the torso so we
raise one arm
and make sure that the elbow is straight
and the hand is pointing
up yeah completely vertical and then
slide the hand that is on your leg down
until you can touch your knee or even
pass it yeah like this and then hold the
stretch for a few seconds
and then use the hand that is up to pull
yourself
up again into a straight line and then
drop the arm
and then we do it with the other side
okay so we do it four times to each side
let's start one go down
hold it and up
one go down
[Music]
two go down
hold it and pop
hold the stretch and up
three slide down
hold the stretch up
three go down hold the stretch
and up and the last one four
go down hold the stretch
up and the last one on this side
and up okay good now
we open the legs we bend the knees a
little bit and make sure that your
hip is straight yeah and then you make a
circle with your arms
keep the hip and the head always looking
forward
and rotate the torso left and right
together with your arms the arms and the
torso move together
yeah don't move the arms alone okay and
we do it 16 times
eight times to each side okay
let's go one two
three four
five six seven
and eight eight more one
two three
[Music]
four five six
seven and eight okay
now we stretch the knees and we put the
hands behind
our head and then we bend forward
until our back is straight and parallel
with the floor
yeah you should feel a slight
stretch on the back of your legs and
then
you keep dropping yeah use the
weight of the head to let it hang yeah
and then balance three times
yeah one two three
and then you put your back straight
again and then you go up
yeah this will stretch the back of your
legs
which will give you a nicer step and
also
the lower back the lower part of your
back which will give you a better
posture so we will do it eight times
okay let's go one
go down bounce
bounce bounce and go up
two go down bounce
bars palms go up
three down bounce bounce
bounce and up very relaxed
yeah four bounce bounce
bounce very relaxed and up
five bounce balls
bounce and up
six bounce bounce
seven go down bounce
bounce
okay now keep the legs open like this
and grab your hips with the hands and
then
go a little bit back with the hips and
we will do circles with the hips
so you move the hip to the side make
sure that you keep your
knees straight yeah and the heels on the
floor
and then front yeah and then to the
other side
yeah as much side as you can yeah and
keep the head in the same place
and then back and you complete one
circle we will do
eight circles in one direction and then
eight circles in the other direction
okay so start behind and let's go
one very big yeah two
as big as you can three
four five
six seven
and eight and now we change direction
one
two three
four five
six seven
and eight okay and now the last
exercise we put our feet together again
and we bend the knees and make sure that
your legs are together
yeah that there is no space between them
together
yeah and then we go down and we bounce
three times very relaxed
one two three and then we stretch the
knees
and we go up on the toes yeah so you
push down the floor
so that your body goes up yeah make sure
that your legs are not opening like this
that you keep them
close yeah if you want you can put your
hands on the hips
or have the arms uh just
hanging on the sides yeah as you prefer
so let's do it
um eight times yeah go down
one bounce bounce bounce
and then go up hold it for three seconds
and go down two bounce
bounce bounce stretch knees go up
hold it for three seconds
and go down three bounce bounce
bounce stretch the knees go up hold it
and go down four bounce bounce
bounce go up
hold it and go down
five bounce bounce bounce stretch the
knees go up
hold it go down
six bounce bounce bounce stretch the
knees
go up hold it make your
core tight so you can keep the position
and down seven
bounce bounce bounce go up
hold it engage the core
and down on the last one bounce bounce
bounce stretch the knees go up
hold it and go down slowly
yeah controlled and slow okay good
let's go for the first exercise okay in
this first exercise i will show you the
simplest sequence that the man can do in
the heel of the woman
and the sequence looks like this you
start in zero position
and then you do a small step forward the
step is small yeah it's
just like this because you're walking
inside the heel of the woman
and the woman is right in front of you
unless you want to do a deep sacada in
the heel
yeah you just want to step where
her foot is so that's right in front of
you yeah
so you do a small step forward then
you do a t step i call it t because the
feet
are placed in a t figure yeah like this
and like this and it's 90 degrees to the
side
yeah after this step you do a 180 degree
pivot
yeah and then a step front
yeah and then you keep repeating this
structure
all the time so you always do a 90
degrees
t step and then 180 degrees
pivot and a front step 90 degrees
distance
and then 180 degrees from
step yeah t and period
and t and p always the same
yeah now if you notice every time you do
this
this little sequence of t and p would
you are using
three quarters of a full circle
yeah because the
if you start in this direction for
example if this is my direction towards
the camera
after the first step the t takes 90
degrees
and the pivot takes 180 so that's 270
that's three quarters so now i finished
90 degrees
short from where i started if i do it a
second time
90 degrees t and then 180 degrees people
now i finish
here so it's 90 degrees less from when
i finish the last time so i do it a
third time
90 degrees deep 180 degrees p1 now i'm
in this direction
90 degrees less so i need to do it a
fourth time
90 degree speed 180 degrees pivot
to finish in the direction that i
started so you need to do it
four times or what is the same
eight steps in order to do a complete
revolution where you finish on the
starting direction
so we will do it eight times to each
side okay
now before we start i would also like
to show you what the woman is doing
meanwhile you do this combination so how
this combination that you are doing
relates to the heel
yeah so let's see what the woman is
doing
um imagine that you just did a basic
step
and you let and you lead the woman into
a cross
okay the woman is in a cross in front of
you
and then you start the hero yeah by
leading
another forward to her and then she's
going to start doing the heel around you
so as you know the woman is going to do
front side and back
around you three steps and these are the
first three steps of your combination so
when you are here now i show you from
the back
yeah the woman is in the cross in front
of you
and then she has the first touch of
forward around you towards the right
side
so when she does it what you forward you
step forward and you take
her place yeah then she does the side
step around you
so when she does the side step you do
the t and you step
between her feet yeah now
she does the back step and she's going
uh towards your back yeah so you follow
her leg
you know and you do a pivot and then you
step with her
yeah now she does after the these three
steps
yeah i show you again front
side and back now she does
a small side step a small sidestep
which you don't follow you wait you
don't step when she does this because
this is a transition step that we use
in which she does it in half time so
faster
and this transition step has the effect
of
changing the system of the next three
steps of the heel
so if the first three steps front side
back
uh you step with her and you were in
parallel system
then she has this little extra step that
you don't follow
and this changes the system so the next
three steps
forward side and back will be in cross
system
yeah so let's see it again you're in
zero position
she's in across in front of you watch
your forward to your right
you go front side step of the woman you
do the t
in between her feet back step of the
woman
pivot and firm you step with her little
transition step of the woman in half
time you don't do anything
front step yeah you do the t
and you step in between her front step
now side step so you pivot
and you step front in between her feet
for the side step now she moves back
back step so you follow her leg and you
do the t
okay 90 degrees and then she does the
transitions the
small side steps so you don't do
anything you wait here
and then she does front yeah side front
so on the front step you pivot and you
step front again
and then she does the side step you do
the t again
in between her feet and then after the
session she does the back step the last
backstep
and you pivot with her and you start
with her and that's it
yeah eight steps i hope you could follow
this explanation
more or less but if you have problems
imagining what the woman is doing
meanwhile you do the combination
don't worry too much because you just
have to trust
the structure you just need to remember
that you do at 90 degrees and then 180
degrees people
and that's all yeah tea and people trust
this combination
because then when you do the hero with
the woman with your partner
you will have developed a muscle memory
for this combination and
it will work with her steps yeah
okay so um we will do it
to both sides we will do the hero to the
right
and then to the left and to change the
size we will use
a little trick um as a transition from
one
side to the other and it will be like
this let's say that you have been doing
the combination to the right
and you are doing the last step which is
pivot
and front with left yeah so when you do
this step
that's the last one then you go back
with the same foot
yeah you go front and back and you
change weight
and then you can start with the right
foot and then you do the whole thing
to the other side yeah so i do it
once for you you can do it with me once
slowly without the metronome just to
just to get the combination in our heads
with the transition
yeah you would start in zero position
and then you would uh start with a hero
to the
right side yeah so you start with left
left front one t
two pivot three
t four pivot
five t six
pivot seven t eight
pivot front and then change weight
and now one with right
two d three
build four d
five people six
t seven pivot eight
t and then finish keyword
change weight and left again yeah
i hope that was clear so we will do it
with the method
and we will do it very slowly so you
have time to
watch it see how it works understand it
and copy it okay we will do it six times
yeah we'll do the eight steps first to
the
right then transition to the left and
then again to the right
to the left to the right to the left
yeah we will do it with a
metronome 58 bpm
yeah two bits per bar yeah
so one two down bit
up it and we will always step on the one
on the dummy only yeah so it will be
one two
three so very slowly so you have time to
focus
on the technique yeah
so let's start
get ready make sure you have enough
space between you and the wall because
you are going to be
turning around so you need a little bit
of space yeah
so zero position arms
embrace put your weight on the right
because you will use the left
as the first step and we go
one two
three four
five six
seven eight
front and change
one two
three four
five six
seven eight
and front and
change to the right one
two three 4
5 6
7 8
1 and change to the left
one two
three four
five six
seven eight
and one and
change one
two three
four five
six seven
eight and one
and change and
one two
three four
five six
seven eight
and one and change
okay yes
how you could follow the combination
now we will do it again but in half time
so double as fast
so we will step on every bit yeah on the
downbeat and on the upbeat so it will be
one two three
four and so on yeah and then the
transition and change side
and we will do it again um six
times three times to each side
okay so technical tips um
to do it better now it's very important
to do the whole combination with your
knees
bent yeah you should really flex
your legs and do the whole combination
uh kind of glow yeah the second thing
is that your torso is always
anticipating
the next step so when you do the front
step
you are already turning the torso to the
side for the t
when you do the t you are already
looking a bit behind you
for the pivot your torso is always a bit
ahead yeah anticipating the next
direction
this will help you a lot and the last
thing is that when you are doing the
keyboard
yeah the 180 degrees pivot try
not to do the pivot with the feet closed
like this
yeah because it doesn't look so good and
it
compromises a bit the balance what i
recommend is that when you do the pivot
try to leave your foot behind like this
yeah and then when you finish the pivot
then
you close the feet for the next step
yeah so the people looks like this
one and step yeah okay
this will come with experience with
practice yeah okay
so let's do it together like before
zero position put your weight on the
right because we will start with the
left
with the heel to the right okay in half
side
and one two
three four five
six seven eight
one change one
two three four
five six seven
eight one change
one two three
four five six
seven eight one
change one two
three four five
six seven eight
one change one
two three four
five six seven
eight one change
one two three
four five six
seven eight one
change okay
great
good so let's go to the next exercise
okay in this exercise we will change the
structure
of the sequence of steps that the mind
is doing in the heat of the woman
and what we will do is to introduce
a change of weight we fit together yeah
every time we do a t yeah so when you
are doing the t
usually what we did before was 180
degrees pivot
and then step front it would be very
similar
you will do the t and then you will
change you will turn 180 degrees
change weight and then front but with
the other leg
okay so even if we are changing the
structure
of the sequence we are not changing the
directions of the steps the directions
of our steps are the same as before
because remember that the woman is still
doing
always the same front side back side
frontier
so her hero will always have the same
shape that means that our directions the
directions of our steps should
always be the same we just are changing
which leg does what yeah so let's see
how our combination
looks like now very slowly remember that
the woman is in front of you
and she's doing front side
and back those are the first three steps
so you go
front that's the first step like before
and then you do the tip
just like before yeah and then here
that's her side step she's going back
so instead of pivoting with her and
stepping with her
with the with a free leg what i do
is on her side step i pivot with her
but then i change weight in half time
and i
uh step forward with the same leg that
did the build
okay then after this
she's going front so i do a normal pivot
180 degrees
and then front okay so this is like
before
then we do another thing so we use the
same trick
180 degrees people change weight and
front with the same length
in the pivot and then we do another 180
degrees
even normal and step on the other leg
and then we do
the last thing yeah because we didn't
already eight steps with this one
so now instead of
doing this yeah what we will do
is uh the same transition
that we did in the last exercise to be
able to change the direction of the heel
so here you will do t pivot
change weight and side step and then
change weight and then you can
use the right leg to go forward and then
the heel will be to the left
yeah so let's do it to the left once
without the metronome very slowly so you
understand what's going on
so you start with the front step with
the right
and then you do the t yeah
then you 180 degrees pivot change weight
front and then you 180 degrees
and front then you know another thing
180 degree spirit change and front
and then you do 180 degrees in front and
then you do the last thing
the last thing here and then you do only
90 degrees five change weight
and side step yeah you are again in the
same direction looking to the wall as
when you start
and then change weight and then you can
do it
with the front leg with the left
so that you do the heel again to the
right yeah i hope that was clear
remember that when you are doing the t
the woman is doing the side step and
when you are doing the pivot and the
change rate in front
the woman is going back yeah that's how
it will work
later in the hero with the woman okay so
let's meet with the metal room again
very slowly
so we will step on the downbeat only
yeah like before
one two
three yeah so you will have a lot of
time to
understand what's going on and to do
each step
okay so let's do it together get ready
zero position
and put your weight on the right because
we will start with the left foot front
and we will do the hero to the right
okay and
one two
and three four
five six
seven eight
and sign on
one two
and
one three
four five
five six
seven eight
and change one
two and three
four five and
six seven
eight on side
and one
two one three
four five five
six seven
eight and side
[Applause]
six seven
eight and side
time okay yeah
good now we have to do it in half time
so we will step on each bit of the metro
yeah
one two three
four okay so
let's do it three times to each side
and starting with the right side okay so
put your weight on the
right and we start with the left
and one two and
three four five and six
seven eight and change and
one two and three
four five and six
seven eight and side and one
two and three four
five and six seven
eight and side and one
two and three four
five and six seven
eight on side and one
two and three four
five and six seven
eight and side and one
two and three four
five and six seven
eight and style
okay
great watch this part as many times
as you need until you get the
combination
it takes a while to memorize the whole
thing and not get lost
with the directions but it just takes
practice yeah
and this will be very very helpful every
time you are doing the hero with the
woman
and doing front change weight and front
it's a really nice effect okay let's go
to the next exercise
okay in this exercise we will introduce
another change in the structure
of the steps of the mind in the hero of
the woman
so we will use again the side step of
the woman remember when she does
front side and back the side step
to do a trick the sidestep of the woman
is an
ideal place to change weight and change
legs
because then she does the back step
which has a lot of
inertia and the trick is a very nice way
to go into the next step that has so
much inertia it's it's very effective
okay so what we will do is this remember
that the woman is doing
front side and back
so what we want is to do a little sakada
front
on her side step yeah so
it looks like this let's do it very
slowly
uh just the first three steps to show
you what the idea
is she's in front of you and she has the
ocho forward to your right so you do
this
front step like before now when she does
the side step
usually you do the t yeah 90 degrees
so we want to keep this direction
obviously because that's where her side
step is
but we don't want to do it with this leg
we want to do it with the other leg
so for that we need to do this movement
after the front step we do a 90 degree
we cross back and we use the same leg
again
that did the front step to do
the second front step yeah so this is
the beginning
of the combination front pivot cross
back
front in half time yeah then
that's the side step and then she goes
back yeah
which is going this way on our back so
here we will do
another interesting movement where we go
from one front step to another front
step
in the other direction yeah so we are
doing
front then we are doing 180 degrees
pivot like before
but with the wrong foot so it looks like
this
yeah instead of this
kind of movement yeah it's the same
thing but with the other leg
this kind of movement yeah and then from
here
the woman is doing the little side step
there is a connection where you don't do
anything
and then front side back so we
will do 180 degrees pivot
normal one and then a strong step
and here we repeat the same structure
again
after this front step we do 90 degrees
pivot crossbar
front with the same leg and then we do
the front
front thing yeah with front pivot
front and then 180 degrees
and flat and then this is the last
time we moved the trick to this side
with
one last time 90 degrees fuel to
crossbar
and front and then here we already did
eight steps so it's time to change the
direction of the heel
so we need a transition step to be able
to do that
and here is where usually we will do the
front step
pivot and front but instead of doing
front like this
what we will do is only 90 degrees
and side yeah and this would simulate
um something as if we were cutting the
heel of the woman
in order to start another heel to the
other side
yeah so you do the last one step
and then side and then change weight
and then you can use the left leg to
initiate the same thing
to the other side yeah to the to the
left
so let's look to the left slowly front
and then the trick yeah pivot crossbar
front 90 degrees then front front with
the pivot
front front and then 180 degrees pivot
front then the thickening pivot cross
back
front and then the front front step
front
front and then 180 degrees pivot
step front and then the last time we do
the trick
keyboard cross back front and then
side step okay change weight and then
front okay i hope you could follow um
we will do it again six times to each
side
slowly with the metronome stepping only
on the downbeat one and
two times okay good
so let's uh let's do it
so get ready and listen very slowly put
your weight on the right
foot because we will start with left and
we will
initiate the heel to the right okay
so one
two three
four and five
six seven
on eight on side
and change now to the left one
two three
four and five
six seven
and eight and side
change to the right one
and two three
four and five
six seven
and eight and side
and eight and
side change
front and two
three four
and five
six seven
and eight and side
change one
one two three
four and five
six
okay and if you want you can keep going
keep going
yeah okay okay so now we will do it
but in half time stepping on each bit of
the metronome yeah
one and two three
four and five and so on okay
so get ready remember to do
the whole combination down low
on your knees and not to make the steps
too big because remember we are dancing
inside the heel of the woman
okay so put your weight on the right
foot because we will start
with the left front to do the heel to
the right
okay so
um one and two
three four and five
six seven and eight side
and one and two three
four and five six
seven and eight side
three four and five
six seven and eight
side and one and two
three four and five
six seven and eight
side and one and two
three four and five
six seven and eight
side
okay good
that was really good okay so let's go to
the last combination
okay in this last exercise we will
combine both tricks
yeah so the first trick remember was
when you do the t yeah then instead of
pivot and front with the other leg you
do
t people change your weight and front
with the same leg that
the people yeah that was the first trick
and the second trick
was um front and
instead of doing the t you do the t but
with the other leg
so you do 90 degrees pivot cross bar
and front with the same leg yeah and
remember if you get lost
that all these tricks always happen when
the woman is doing the side step
yeah so on the first trick the woman is
doing the front step then the side step
so you do the t and then she does the
back step
so you pivot change your weight and
follow her back step with the same leg
and on the other trick she does the
front torso you front and then on
her side step you people 90 degrees
cross back and then step with a sakada
if you want
yeah but in any case in between her feet
on her side step
yeah with this leg so let's see slowly
how the combination looks like yeah we
will do it without the metronome
very slowly so that you understand the
structure so you start in zero position
and the woman
starts the hero with the ultra forward
going to your right
okay so you do the front step with left
this is always the same
now we use this the first trick so when
she does the side step
you do the t and then on the back step
you do people change weight and follow
her
with a front step with the same leg that
did the pivot that's her backstab
then she does the little side step that
you weight
and then she does front side back so now
you
pivot 180 degrees front
and then in this step that's when she's
going to do the side step
you do the second trick people 90
degrees cross back
front and then here you do the front
front step front pivot front
and then here you do another 180 english
pivot
and front step yeah and here
is when she goes to the side again so
you will do
another t and this will be again the
first stick
um people to exchange away but because
this is the last step we already did
eight steps
we need to go to the trick to change the
direction of the heel
so here we do only 90 degrees pivot
and side step yeah and then change
weight
and then we can do it with the other leg
with our right starting with the right
so the heel will go to the left
so let's do it slowly to the other side
front okay she's going from side back
so you 90 degrees key people
change weight front then you do 180
degrees
front and here you do the second trick
cross back front then you do front front
front front 180 degrees
front and then this is the last step
yeah lastly so you do 90 limit speed
change side change weight and then you
start with left
okay we will do it now six times
slowly yeah with a metronome stepping
only on the downbeat
one and two so you will have the
chance to see it repeat it many times
very slowly so you can
catch it okay so let's do it
with the metronome very slowly so
zero position put your weight on the
right because we will start
with the front step with the left leg
and the heel is going to the right okay
so let's start
one two
and three
four and five
six seven
eight on side
and one
two and three
four and five
six seven
eight on
five six
seven eight
and side and
one two
and three
four and five
six seven
eight and side
and one
two and three
four and five
six seven
eight on
[Music]
six
okay great so
now we will do it in half time stepping
on a little bit
of the metal yeah so it will be like one
and two three four and
five six and so on okay
so let's do it zero position
bend the knees remember do the whole
combination
low no don't do very big steps
because you are stepping inside the heel
of the woman
yeah and remember to anticipate
with the torso yeah the direction of the
next step so your person is always in a
kind of spiral
okay so let's go wait on the right and
we start with
left front to do the heel to the right
and one two and
three four and five
six seven eight and
side and one two and
three four and five
six seven eight and seven
and one two and three
four and five six
seven eight and side and
one two and three
four and five six
seven eight and side and
one two and three
four and five six
seven eight and style and one
two and three four and five
six seven eight and seven once more
one two and three
four and five six
seven eight
okay great
very good so i hope you
liked this exercise today the last class
of 2020
and yeah even if it's a bit complicated
just watching many times practice if you
have problems following the sequence
break it down in parts yeah for example
when you want to do it fast and you get
lost well
try to learn the first three steps of me
just do the first three steps
fast with the mental role yeah and then
when the three steps are no problem
then put the fourth step and you do the
four
first steps and then the fifth and then
you will get used to it and you will
complete the whole combination and you
will be able to do the whole thing
repeatedly
yeah and i really recommend you to
practice these sequences because
uh as you have seen we have used
different tricks
in the hero with changes of weight with
crosses back
and then we have combined the tricks
yeah and this when you
dance with your partner it will give you
lots of ideas
for improvising for changing which leg
you use
in the middle of a heel yeah it will
give you ideas to change the structure
of your heel on the fly
and do the same steps sometimes with the
left leg
sometimes with the right sometimes
crossing back sometimes doing a double
time
forward you will be able to use all
these tricks
on the fly to improvise and change your
the structure of your heel which is
something that will give your heroes
a lot of interest yeah if you change
their structure
on the fly okay so that was it thank you
very much and thank you for the people
who are supporting the channel with
donations i really appreciate that
and i will see you in the next class bye